I think it's got to be Demerzel.
I like to be Demerzel, I think.
Oh, I want to play you.
25,000 years old,
Demerzel, kind of quietly behind
the scenes, running things, being sly.
Laura does it so well.
I don't want to touch it,
but... I think
it'd be fun trying to understand
what it's like to be a robot.
And she navigates that performance
so beautifully.
Oh if I could play any character
it would probably be Dawn.
Dawn changes a lot, obviously, because of
the way the nature of the Cleons.
Cassian, who plays Dawn,
gets to do so many things as an actor,
and that's really exciting.
The Emperor of the Galaxy.
Very simple.
No.
I think I would be a good leader
like openly.
Okay.
Alright.
I mean, the obvious answer is the Prime Radiant.
I think in some way that the Vault
is more impressive than the Prime Radiant.
There's like a device in season one where
you can kind of put this laser thing over
something and just fix it.
That Salvor
uses on the Invictus,
and I think that's a great thing
that I would love to have.
I do like the... the bracelet.
The protective Aura.
I am so clumsy
like I trip and fall all the time
and I get bruises all the time
so I probably would save myself
from all of that if I had one of those.
Oh, I think I already did.
Do you trust the math?
I definitely could not win a galaxy
wide math contest.
There's no way that Hari Seldon
would ever pick me as a prodigy.
Um, no.
No no no,
I, uh. I really suck at math.
I reckon I could win a Galaxy wide
math contest if it was trigonometry,
because I actually hilariously
used to do that as a hobby,
just like solve trigonometry
when I was younger.
Wouldn’t we all like to mind read?
I think that would save me a lot of time.
I definitely nerded out on the fact
that the Prime Radiant
we explain is a quantum device.
It's in a state of superposition,
which means it can
sort of be in two places at once.
I love that.
I love that the Vault is a tesseract,
meaning it's bigger on the inside
than it is on the outside, because I think
that's really mind blowing
and I love where that mind takes me.
I sure would love to have a Bishop's Claw
that I could just ride and
it would defend me
if anyone attacked me.
I think that one's pretty cool.
See yeah, this is the question.
This is the question.
I hope so,
isn't that where we're headed?
I don't know,
you guys tell me.
I mean.
Uh no, definitely not.
We should all be scared of AI.
I think we
probably can exist peacefully,
but we're going to have to compromise
on some things
I reckon.
It's so complicated,
and also, I mean, you look at
it happening right now.
I know people who look at their phones
more than they look at their spouse.
The beautiful thing
about like communicating with a human
is that you always have to take a risk
that you don't know how the other person
is going to communicate with you,
kind of like falling in love.
It's always a risk.
Easy, easy deal.